aging it's what we do and what I'm here
to talk about today in particular
addressing a recent paper that claims to
test the information Theory of Aging
that has come up from Davis and Claire's
Lab at Harvard Medical School and claims
to drive aging both forwards and
backwards
so first I'll present the necessary
background for the information Theory of
Aging and how the authors describe their
findings then we'll look at the data to
see to what extent the data supports
their viewpoints and then we'll take a
look at some other opinions and then
I'll say what I think and how I would
test the information Theory it's such
fun such fun
wait for it such fun there it goes such
fun indeed all right
so the first thing we need to address is
this information Theory of Aging
if we break it apart the main question
you're probably asking is well what
information
the classical view of information
storage within a cell is pinned to our
genome DNA that contains all our genetic
information three billion base pairs of
it DNA being stable easily accessed for
reading the information and being used
as a convenience copying method of
semi-conservative replication means that
our genetic information is by and large
preserved as we gave from a fertilized
egg to a grown adult
but while our cells have the same DNA
our cells are different that comes down
to what genes are being expressed by how
much and at what time they are expressed
what governs this gene expression
control is currently thought to be
epigenetic marks heritable yet
modifiable marks found in over DNA
itself or in the proteins that compact
DNA
together these proteins and DNA as
referred to as chromatin
take note as I'll mention us later
and so one analogy that David used in
this book lifespan to describe these
epigenetic marks is that of a DVD yes I
still know what they are whereby DNA is
likely the hardware
the information stored in the DVD while
the surface represents the epigenetic
information
the disk can stay intact but the
information can get harder to read and
get perturbed as the surface of the disk
gets grubby or scratched
in short Ben David's information Theory
of Aging is that there seems to be a
loss of this epigenetic information
during aging that could be reversed as
then you can clean your DVD
the consequence of this loss with
regarding regarding a cell is that gene
expression and other cellular processes
like DNA repair become faulty and it
causes cells to behave aberrantly and
lose their identity
now David is not the only to propose
that there is a connection between
epigenetic changes and aging in fact
epigenetic alterations is one of the
Hallmarks of aging and changes in DNA
methylation are being used to build
so-called DNA methylation slash aging
epigenetics political Asian clocks which
I've discussed many times before but are
these epigenetic changes just a
consequence of Aging or a natural cause
well David's information Theory of Aging
goes a step further and extends upon the
simple scratching of a DVD analogy and
suggests that these changes are due to
the cellular response to DNA damage
daily damage typically activates
that is p53
and this includes its response to
double-stranded breaks as you can see
here
whereby p53 is activated to mediate the
DNA repair response and this can result
in epigenetic changes
and so as describes in Davis book
lifespan wherever epigenetic factors
leave the genome to address the damage
genes that should be off switch on and
vice versa wherever they stop in the
genome they do the same altering the
epigenome in ways that were never
intended when we were born
cells lose their identity and
malfunction chaos and shoes the chaos
materializes as aging this is the
epigenetic noise that is at the heart of
our unified theory
as another term they used to describe
this phenomenon is RCM relocalization of
Chromatin modifiers the idea that the
protein factors that are involved in
changing these epigenetic marks moved to
sites of damage and are therefore not
why they should be because they're
getting distracted or if they try to
return they end up returning to the
incorrect place
so this all sounds very great and sort
of hand wavy but how do we go about
testing this well you would want to see
if you can find a way to advance aging
by increasing the rate of these changes
in epigenetic marks and then also show
that you can slow down or reference
aging by restoring slash maintaining
slash preserving slash conserving slash
prolonging slash I'll stop reading the
thesaurus the epigenetic information so
how to do this well the first
appreciation of this Theory as David
describes in his book is that if the
information theory is correct that aging
is caused by overworked epigenetic
signalers responding to Cellular insult
and damage it doesn't matter where the
damage occurs
so you need to induce some sort of
damage and this brings us back to this
recent paper where they describe the
creation of a mouse strain that they
call ICE mice Ice Hair standing for
inducible changes to the epigenome
now this point is really important they
wanted to make changes to the epigenome
by causing double-stranded breaks but
double stranded breaks can result in DNA
mutations another Theory of Aging
with a lot of evidence behind it so they
claim to have found a method that
induces double strand breaks that get
repaireds causing changes to the
epigenome but the DNA sequence Remains
the Same this involved using an
inducible system where they could
control the this effect with an
exogenous enzyme
ippa1 which David entertainingly
describes in his book as an enzyme that
comes from QP yellow slime and it floats
around and cuts DNA at just a few places
in the mouse genome the cell has no
problem pasting the DNA strands back
together leaving their mutations which
is exactly what we were looking for to
engage the survival circuit and distract
the Saturns
to turn into our family of proteins some
of which are involved in epigenetic
marks but that's as much as I'll talk
about them today anyway I feel like this
explanation is already getting too long
so let's recap they made a male strain
these mice contained an inducible enzyme
that only gets activated if a cell
receives the drug tamoxifen a commonly
used research tool and when this enzyme
gets activated it causes double strand
breaks in the genome the cell
accordingly fixes the damage and in
response to this it could change the
epigenetic mark slash distracts the
epigenetic factors from their usual
roles along with the information Theory
of Aging relocalization of Chromatin
modifiers
so what happens well I first learned
about their results back in
2019 when I read Davis book
where it says the mice might have died
they might have grown tumors or they
might have been perfectly fine no worse
off than if they received the dental
x-ray
nobody had done this before in a mouse
so we didn't know but if our hypothesis
and epigenetic instability and aging was
correct to moxifan remember this as
activating the sunshine would work like
the potion that Fred and George Weasley
used to age themselves and Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire and it worked
like Wizardry it did I like one of my
favorite scenes from Harry Potter as you
can see in these images the mice that
received tamoxifen for three weeks in
four to six month old mice do look much
older and performed worse in memory
tasks at 10 months post-treatment these
ice mice exhibited classic features of
old age including reduced body weight
and fat Mass independent of food intake
and they had a lower respiratory rate
during the day and decrease Motion in
the dark phase
but firstly how did this treatment
affect the cells
while firstly not all of the cells of
the mouse got damaged I think that's
important to point out and that's just
the limitation of the method that they
use to activate the enzyme so it's not
clear how many of the cells received
this damage response but they've
estimated that it was between 60 to 70
percent of cells within the muscle liver
hippocampus and cortex the latitude just
parts of the brain but I don't recall
seeing information of other cell types
such as the immune system which when
prematurely aged in a separate paper
through DNA damage does Drive senescence
and aging
now the reason I went into so much
detail to explain the system is that it
is clearly an artificial way to induce
damage and long term that they did see
that this treatment caused the cells to
become senescence and immune cells are
involved in senescence clearance so it
would be interesting to see if they
could do tissue specific male strains
where they had a better idea over what
tissues they were actually damaging or
artificially aging
but let's go back to see if they tested
the theory the epigenetics that they
change
well obviously there were some changes
in this paper they profiled the history
modifications the the proteins that wrap
up DNA and in some cells they also look
at the epigenetic age so they look at
DNA methylation and a long story shorts
they are different to mice that didn't
get induced with the damage so so far so
good so we see some epigenetic changes
and we see The Miser order however it's
still not clear if these epigenetic
changes are correlating or actually
causal for aging so that brings us to
the second test can you restore the
pattern of epigenetic marks in the cells
that got damaged and to achieve this
they delivered three of the yamanaka
factors ox4 sucks II and klf4 using an
adeno-associated virus to the ice mice
and then they looked five weeks later
they show that levels of one Mark a
histone Mark it's free canine
trimethylation of cells in the kidney
match control mice but that's kind of
like the only days that they really
present so I have missed out a lot of
their data figures but frankly this
video is getting quite long and would
require much explanation from my side to
go through all of the plots so let's
hear first how the authors concludes and
then we'll move on to thoughts of others
and my own
so the authors conclude that by
introducing double strand breaks without
causing mutations we provide evidence
that this is the cell's reaction to the
damage and the resulting loss of
epigenetic information that drives
mammalian aging forwards this would
explain why aging proceeds through a
predictable series of molecular and
physiological changes even though DNA
damage can occur anywhere in the genome
fortunately it is now apparent that
mammals retain a backup copy of youthful
epigenetic information that can safely
restore the function of all tissues akin
to reinstalling software
so after reading this paper quite a few
times I agree that whatever they did to
the mice caused them to display
phenotypes that overlap of Aging
what I don't fully follow is the origin
of the landscape in terms of the
epigenetic information as something like
cellular senescence does that already
and they seem to focus on histone
modifications individually at different
parts of the paper which made it
narratively quite hard to follow but
that isn't their main conclusion of
course they also did this yamanako
Rejuvenation later on in the paper but I
don't think they provide much data
regarding that aspect
they didn't look at all the tissues and
they didn't do any lifespan studies
which would have been the kind of
obvious entity if they were able to both
prematurely age and also rejuvenate the
mice
but the authors are also aware of some
of their limitations and they do say as
well that they didn't determine which
chromatin factors are relocalized nor
did we study chromatin contacts and Vivo
that is to say this RCM relocalization
of Chromatin modifiers part of their
hypothesis wasn't really tested or
examined
so I don't think that data fully
supports their overall claims of
restoration of the epigenetic landscape
information Theory of Aging but I don't
think it disproves it if anything I just
thought it raised more questions and
this paper also caused quite a star over
on Twitter but I think this quote by
jean-vay says it best the jump that now
aging is a program that can be burned
backwards isn't justified by their
research
But ultimately you know being the
interested and informative researcher
that I am the key question is well if
this method that they developed doesn't
test this Theory how would we test it
well I did spend some time thinking
about it and the only thing I could
think of was to use crispr activation
and in that activation methods for
precise epigenetic editing because here
you can modify the epigenetic marks in
precisely occasions of the genome I mean
this wouldn't be trivial to set up and
um Good Luck guys I don't really know
how you would do it
um or why you would Target it
but at least you would have a better
understanding of what the cell's initial
response would be and there wouldn't be
any double strand breaks
and so
yeah but the best part is I have made a
video on this tool before so you can
learn about it here and with that I hope
you've learned something thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening
don't say such fun well if it annoys you
that much no I won't
such fun
such fun oh a double